14% c'est la baisse de fréquentation du
salon de l'automobile de paris par
rapport à 2014 mais du côté des
concessionnaires locaux le mondial de
l'auto offre des opportunités
c'est le cas du groupe courtois à
montigny le bretonneux qui organisait
des portes ouvertes le week end dernier
on a battu le record 1 ce week-end de
vente on a vendu sur ce site plus de 30
véhicules et fait plus de 100 essais
tous modèles confondus ces chiffres
s'expliquent par une organisation
spécifique lors du mondial de
l'automobile de paris en fait on est en
interconnecté avec les équipes du salon
les clients vont voir vont voir la gamme
vont découvrir deux mots de nouveaux
modèles éventuellement ils vont voir des
modèles plus existants il ya des
conditions spécifiques au salon et nous
ensuite on est mis en relation via via
internet on a des positions d'achat ou
décès et on a su ensuite le travail en
concession de proximité pour faire
essayer la gamme aller plus loin dans la
dans l'explication des différents
modèles et après on peut leur faire
bénéficier le cas échéant de conditions
spécifiques ou de destination de leurs
véhicules pour les reprendre après un an
de travaux cette concession vient de
réouvrir ses portes une rénovation pour
digitaliser certaines activités offertes
par la structure objectif proposer une
montée en gamme du service rendu au
client à l'époque une mise en main ce
qu'on appelait la découverte de l'ecl
prenait un quart d'heure vingt minutes
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur des
schémas de plusieurs fois une heure on
fait une première une première
explication première mise en main on a
après des casques virtuelles qui
permettent de faire découvrir tout ce
qui aide à la conduite c'est comme dans
l'informatique il faut plusieurs
plusieurs fois pour bien maîtriser
l'outil donc on a obligé d'avoir des
commerciaux
de très haut niveau ce que l'on a et on
les forme énormément ça internet permet
aux clients de choisir son véhicule sur
le web face à ces différentes évolutions
et à la concurrence le métier de
concessionnaire temps à s'adapter à ces
défis du 21e siècle